[music]
>> Welcome everyone. Hi, how are you doing?
Okay, okay, that's more like it. How's
the energy in the room? I'm Sona
Karashkevich. I'm a group product
manager with a one V team here at
Google. And you may have seen our show
earlier this morning. I'm Mitchell. I
work on anti-gravity.
Awesome. And we're going to tell you all
about what's new in Google AI Studio and
anti-gravity. Just right before us, Amar
and Paige, they walked you through all
the experience in Google AI Studio. And
now we're going to go one one step
deeper. Does that work for you? Sounds
like a plan. I think you're going to get
it get it started. Let's let's get
started. Are you guys ready?
Okay, awesome.
So,
at Google DeepMind, our goal is to build
AI responsibly that benefits humanity.
And everything that we do is always with
this goal in mind. We always want to
make sure that everything that we build
from the models, from the products, from
the services, they always benefit
everyone and everyone has a positive
experience with that our technology,
regardless of where you are at, where
your your your language, anything.
And with this very ambitious goal, we we
do
so many different things at DeepMind and
we bring all the best and greatest to
the market. And we now live in a very
special time where you can build
anything.
And in these times in which we can build
anything, the rules of software
development have been written rewritten.
The what and the how are changing
dramatically and how you react truly
matters. And this is why at Google, we
built um a stack and we built an
ecosystem that allows you to to have
tools for every different types of
experiences that you're trying to build.
And we have this very robust ecosystem
that allows you to go from exploration
to development to cloud to cloud
deployment in very seamlessly. And our
products are always powered by the
latest and greatest model innovation.
So, Google AI Studio is becoming a
one-stop shop where you can find the
models that in the playground, agents to
build experience and I'm going to show
you that in just a second. But now we're
building more of these product
integrations. You've heard about the
Google Workspace integration coming to
AI Studio, the Cloud Run into
Antigravity. So, more and more the
Google is ecosystem is being built in a
way that provides you with with a
solution regardless of um what you're
trying to build. And we typically say
that Google AI Studio truly is the
fastest way to go from path the the
fastest way to go from prompt to to app
and and it truly is like that. And and
I'm going to show that to you in a
second. This is what Google AI Studio
really
is and what it looks right now. And it
has evolved so much. Just a few years
ago we were showing Google AI Studio and
it has evolved from being a playground
where you could try and test the models
and the different capabilities to now
being a place where you can try not just
your ideas, but you can also deploy
uh deploy your apps into Cloud Run.
We've been bringing more of these
product integrations, like I mentioned
before, with Google Workspace, but also
with Cloud Run for a one-click
deployment, and more and more
uh we are building a product that is
very robust and and is tailoring catered
to you, so you're able to build anything
that you want.
And the team is building at
relentless relentless pace. When we say
this, honestly, you have to trust me.
Everything happens so so fast. We're
shipping new things almost every day
feels like. And I just wanted to bring
this list of all the things that we've
announced here at IO just so you can see
the sheer amount of work that goes
behind these products that we all love
and use on
on on a daily basis. From the the mobile
app to to direct
deploy to to the Play Store to the
Google Workspace integration to the
Google anti-gravity coding agent,
there's just so so many things that are
coming every single day to our products
and a lot of that is the result of your
feedback, the developer community that
tells us exactly what to improve and how
we should keep improving the experience
for you.
But
better than showing it to you on a
screen, why don't I go on my laptop and
show it to you how it actually works in
the playground. Does that does that
work?
Okay. Okay. So let's let's do this. If
we go
if we go to the the playground, if you
go to the laptop, okay, there we go. So
this is what Google AI Studio looks like
and Paige and Omar, they gave you a very
in-depth overview, so I'm not going to
I'm not going to bother you with that,
but I just wanted to show you the
playground where you have our models,
our new agents and we have different
agents coming to Google AI Studio. For
example, one that I really like is the
data analyst.
And
is is the data analyst. There's a bunch
of of others that you can that you can
try, the customer support, the document
processor, so many different agents for
whatever use case you're trying to do.
Now,
this morning,
we you you might have seen Josh showed
Louis Sinnamon on stage. Do you
remember?
Yes, okay. So, I was really inspired by
his story and how he has to find
pet hotel in order to to keep his pets
safe while he's on holiday. So, I had an
idea. Why don't I actually build um
a new business. And and so, I thought
I'm going to open a pet shop and I'm
going to have a place where we can have
all the pets coming in and spend time at
the hotel. However, I don't know
anything about the pet shop business. Do
you guys know anything at all? Anyone
that can help me? No? Okay. Good thing
that we have agents in AI Studio because
I am going to ask for their help. And
so, I already have a a prompt which I
also refined in Gemini app. And it's a
prompt that is I'm going to ask the
research agent to do a bit of market
research to see if my idea is actually
feasible here in the Bay Area. So, my
prompt I'm going to ask, you are a
premier retail market research analyst
specializing in San Francisco Bay Area
Silicon Valley commercial landscapes.
I'm planning to open an independent
brick-and-mortar pet shop in the region.
I want a comprehensive deep research,
market analysis, and then I specified
everything that I wanted the the
research agent to find. Target
demographics, micro markets, correlate
pet ownership with demographic data,
inventory strategy, recommendations, and
everything. So, I'm going to just
basically paste my prompt
into AI Studio, and I run this earlier
today because, you know, Wi-Fi and
and live demos. And I have here
and this is basically what it looks
like. I gave it my prompt. I saw the
thoughts. I approved the research plan.
It has all the specifications that I
asked it to search for.
And now it has given me a very, very
in-depth report with step-by-step
exactly of what I should do. Now, this
is just one example of the deep research
agent, but if you come here to this
section, you have the the max preview,
which is better for overnight tasks, but
you also have other types of agents that
you can pick and choose and everything
is just available within the same
section of your model selection. Now,
let's say you want a very quick analysis
instead of something that is actually
um very, very time-consuming, you come
here to system instructions, you pick
the the persona that you want the model
the the the system instructions or the
persona you want the model to
um impersonate and you add a
description. You can also add
constraints and they will do the
research for you. So, I click this one.
I'm just going to basically paste the
same prompt and I will just let it run
and it's going to run for a while, um
which is absolutely fine. So, while the
agent is going to to show
the
um its research,
I
I keep thinking, "Okay,
now I have I've done my research. It's a
good opportunity to open my pet shop in
the Bay Area. What should I do next?"
Find a place. Okay, that's a great one,
but how will people know that I have a
pet shop?
Website. Someone said website. Okay,
wonderful.
Wonderful idea. And here is my website.
Let's say that I went back home, started
working on my website, on my inventory.
And this is exactly what it looks like.
What you guys think?
Now, fun fact, all these pets that you
see on screen are actually our pets. Uh
so, you can see Josh's dogs, you can see
my little John, that's my pet. So, this
is all built with pets from Google. So,
I think it's it's like the most
wholesome moment of IO. And this is what
the website looks like, very, very
basic. What do I need now in order to
improve my site?
Come on, guys. Feedback. We're
developing a new product, we develop a
new business, we need feedback.
How can I find How can I get feedback
very, very quickly?
Okay, I'm going to show you. So, this is
what a new app that is coming to the
Google AI Studio um
app section is coming very, very soon.
And this is what it looks like. This is
this probably one of my very, very
favorite. You can remix this app and
what it does is an agentic focus group.
So, it uses different agents to
impersonate different types of user
segments and audiences that you may want
to try to be to attract with your own
business. So, this is extremely useful
if you have an online business, if you
are a startup, if you are a builder
trying to identify your niche audience,
you can basically with with a remix just
adjust whatever persona might be within
your business. For the purpose of this
demo, I'm just going to keep like a a
skeptical CFO, a UX lead, a status
seeker. So, just very like generic
personas, but I'm going to get my
website and I'm going to run it with my
agent focus groups.
And now, while it's analyzing, it's
going to basically give me a
description, what's the sentiment
analysis, what do they think about my
website? And so I can tailor all these
different I I can tailor what they tell
me and and get that feedback into the
next iteration of my website. Now, let's
say I want to keep building my website.
I already know like it's really cute,
but it's not it's not the very best one.
A very cool thing that I can do is come
to Stitch and Stitch is perfect. I can
just say create uh create a landing page
for my pet shop in the Bay Area
and let it run. It will
run and come up with some some
design examples, hopefully.
Uh
Maybe not. There we go.
And if I'm happy with one of the the
design examples that Stitch came up uh
came up with, I can simply export it
into AI Studio and I can keep building
with AI Studio. So, when I give and it
opens directly in the build app and I
can now say build me an app with the
screenshots that look like this and it
will just build a new website for me
that is based off
uh the Stitch designs that were based on
my initial idea. So, that's something
really cool. Now, I'm thinking, okay, so
I've done my market research, I have my
website, I've improved my website with
my my
um
with my Agentic focus groups and this is
what it looks like. So, if you go here,
you can see the analysis, the sentiment,
the match rate are for each one of the
personas. So, let's see the busy
executive says, "Mm while heartwarming,
the current site forces a high friction
time-consuming adoption process." So,
things like that. And as you can see, it
just changes based on the persona that
I'm that I'm choosing. Okay, cool. So,
did my market research, built my
website, improved it with focus groups.
Um I wasn't really happy, built
something new with Stitch, exported to
AI Studio, kept on building. Okay, I
think this business is going to be
successful. What you guys think?
Oh, yeah. Okay, great.
Now, what am I missing?
Inventory. Thank you so much. Now, my
inventory
I've been doing my inventory in a kind
of a basic way. I've been using a Google
Sheet and I have all the ideas, the
different names of the pets of the pets,
the animal type, the breed. I added
pictures, but those pictures are also in
like a Google Drive. Um I have the
health status. Okay, it is it is good,
but it could be a lot better, don't you
agree?
Wait a minute. Google AI Studio now
allows integration with workspace. How
about I also build my next inventory
management dashboard with Google AI
Studio?
Let's do that.
Okay, so I go here, I go to the build
tab, and I say create
create
a dashboard
for my
pet shop and allow for
integration
with Google Sheets for inventory
management.
Okay, and now it's going to build.
Now, as you might have guessed, I have
already preloaded it beforehand, so I'm
going to show exactly what it looks
like. I had given um
I've I had given the model the exact
same prompt, and I kept on iterating it
just just a little bit. So, I improved
some of the color scheme so it would be
a bit more on brand based on the
feedback that I had received from my
agents.
And at at
And while the model is thinking, it had
asked me to integrate with Google
Sheets. Let me just go scroll up.
I can show it to you in the history.
Okay.
Cool.
So, now let's let's give it a try. See
if it works. It does.
Awesome. I now have a an inventory
management tool completely integrated
with Google Sheets, with Google Drive,
and I can see the number the total
number of pets, the number available,
adopted, the health status. I can see
the asset gallery. Um and I can
basically manage
all my different animals here. If I see
something that is not right, so for
example, if I try to find John, John is
not available. John is my cat. I want to
change that. Okay, move it to adopted.
And the cool thing is that you have
real-time um updates both in the app and
in the sheet. So, if you change
something here as well, needs
checkup, it will change in the app. Uh
it it will change in the app as well,
which is really cool. Okay, I've done
everything. Research, website, improve
the the website, built a new one,
created an inventory management. Now my
last step. What is my last step?
Finding clients. Okay, very cool. So, I
go to AI Studio again because I'm like,
okay, I need a strategy and I don't know
how to build that strategy. And I'm
going to ask the model
create
a marketing tool
to help me
with go to market
for my pet shop.
Give me 10
CTAs
and help me
optimize
ads.
Cool.
So, now the model is going to run my
next prompt and basically it's just
given me this result that looks like
um that looks like the dashboard that I
want for my go-to-market strategy. So, I
can literally just come here, get the
link of my website and I am going to
turn this into a growth strategy that
allows me to then literally create any
type of marketing assets, my my hooks,
my visuals. It can integrate with Nano
Banana, with View. You can create a
brand identity, a logo. So, literally
Google AI Studio is becoming a one-stop
shop for startups, for builders, for
small businesses. You can manage and
create an entire business as I just show
you. And now I have my
my growth score based on my current
website. I have a friction analysis. I
have SEO and meta data uh meta data
analysis, all my campaigns in just one
place, plus my ad simulator ready to go,
ready to ship.
Okay. So, this is what I had to show you
in Google AI Studio. Uh there are a few
very cool things that I would highly
recommend you to to test after IO.
Agents is definitely one of them. Cus
customer support, data analysis,
research, and anti-gravity in the AI
studio, and and then some of the new
focus groups that will help you take
your business to the next level.
Um, and one very cool thing that we
brought into AI studio is the
integration is the integration with
anti-gravity, and An Shoal is now going
to show you everything that is new with
the anti-gravity.
Awesome.
Everybody, give Joanna a hand for a
round of applause.
>> [applause]
>> Cool.
Um,
so I'm here to tell you a little bit
more about anti-gravity. You probably
heard about it a little bit throughout
the keynotes today morning. Uh, but
really was going to spend some time here
today to give you a little bit of a kind
of
thought process as how we designed a lot
of the new features in anti-gravity. But
the big announcement today morning was
anti-gravity 2.0.
So when we released the anti-gravity IDE
back in November, it's shockingly only
been six, seven, seven, eight months,
something like that.
Um,
it's we we introduced it primarily as an
AI-powered IDE.
But in the anti-gravity IDE, we did have
a second surface. We called it the agent
manager. And it was kind of our view of
what would the world look like in an
agent-first kind of world, right? If you
think about it, if most of the time your
agents are doing most of the work and
your IDE is
70, 80% not your agent, something seems
off. And so we started designing what
does that actually look like? What
happens when the entire UI starts
focusing on the conversations you have
with your agents, the management of all
of your agents, and any kind of
artifacts and communication that the
agent does with you.
And we were like, okay, we'll put it
there we'll put it there. We won't make
that the primary surface. Let's see if
people actually enjoy this, right? This
is, you know, long before these kind of
like agent-first kind of paradigms
became popular. Um, the short answer was
yes. And so it became pretty clear to us
over the last few months that what we
needed to do is separate out just that
agent-first surface into its own
standalone application. That allows you
to just deal with the agents and if you
want to code with antigravity 2.0,
you're going to use any IDE of your
choice, but if you want to start using
antigravity for more and more tasks
beyond just coding, which you all have,
um now you have this one place, which is
just truly dedicated for that.
And so that's really what the end goal
is, to build the agent first platform
that's built for the next era.
And
Okay, show of hands, how many people are
a little bit tired hearing the word
agents today?
A little bit? Okay.
I'm not going to make it any better. So,
I'm sorry. Um I'm going to be talking a
lot about agents,
but really how do we think about working
with agents in a way that you can get
the most done, you can stay focused,
while also
you know, keeping security and
permissions and all these things top of
mind.
We launched a lot, so these are all kind
of like brand new things that we
launched uh
today. Um
I think you guys found it a little bit
exciting cuz uh you all took down our
authentication services um for just how
many people were trying to log in. It's
all fixed now, so if you you got some
issues earlier today, try again.
Apologies. Um
but there's really a lot that we're
trying to do, right? We're trying to
improve the core agent, the primitives
that it has to do more powerful work
more more quickly and more efficiently
and better.
Um but then we're also thinking about
like how does the UI should actually
evolve so that you're looking at agents
and managing them appropriately cuz
really we believe in a world where you
will have n agents working together
across x different projects and that is
a completely different way of working.
And hopefully that helps everyone kind
of multiply what their output looks
like. And then we added a lot of nice
fun product features as well. So,
I'm just going to take it over to the
the laptop. Now, I'm not going to spend
a whole lot of time actually kind of
like, you know, trying to try trying to
build something. I'm I'm not nearly as
uh
you know,
good with that on live and I think it's
going to take a little bit more time
than than Joanna did. Um there is like a
20-minute demo that Kevin, my
co-presenter during the dev keynote, put
together That's online. Uh that will
show you every single feature in action.
But, what I really wanted to spend today
is kind of walking you through the
Antigravity 2.0, showing you a little
bit of the lay of the land, um
and some of the design decisions that we
took in so that you can get kind of that
internal kind of understanding of how we
thought about building it, and therefore
how you can actually get the most out of
it as well.
Um
so, as you can tell,
I'm not sure, but anyone that does this
look like an IDE?
Not not really. Um yeah, this this is
really it. This is the kind of minimal
kind of entry point to Antigravity 2.0.
It's
you, your agents, and the conversations.
So, um
to to kind of get started, uh
I this is like a kind of a brand new
laptop, so I just started a
uh a task earlier just to be able to
highlight some of the pieces here. So,
in the middle is your conversations with
the agents.
Every agent, every conversation, you can
have it multi-turn, all those things.
On the right,
there's a there's the side panel that
has a lot of different pieces here, and
I'll kind of walk through some of them.
The first part here is sub-agents. So,
this is something that we newly added to
the product.
The reality is, people are trying to do
much more complex tasks with
Antigravity. And, you know, if you have
one agent that's trying to do all the
work, right, you might give it a much
large kind of vague task to to go out
there, and I think we've all seen LLMs
get a little bit confused if it's trying
to multitask itself.
That's that's common. So, what we wanted
to do is make it possible for that main
agent to itself determine that, "Hey, I
have this well-scoped task that needs to
get done.
I should just hand that over to a
sub-agent that's just focused on that
one specific task. It can complete its
work, and then it can report back when
it's done with any kind of outputs that
might be interesting for my main
conversation." And and why is this nice?
It allows the main agent to stay
focused, right, on whatever kind of that
big large vague task you gave to break
it down.
It allows the sub-agents to be really
focused, and it also allows for
parallelization. Right? If you have n
tasks that
could be done at the same time,
might as well do them in parallel.
Um
actually, let's let's kind of show this
show this in action a little bit. So,
I'm going to just start a new
conversation.
Uh we'll we'll open up in a in a new
project. So, I'll talk about projects in
a little bit, but you can also just run
your own standalone conversations if you
have that kind of idea on the side that
you just want to do it. Um I'm going to
be pretty explicit just so you can see
the sub sub agents in action, but I can
say, you know, uh spin up a couple of
sub agents
to tell me all the things
launched in Google anti-gravity
at IO.
So, hopefully, if this this works and
the the demo gods are with us,
um yeah, there we go. So,
what what you just saw here is, really
quickly, a couple of sub agents being
spun up as I pretty explicitly asked in
this this kind of make-up example.
Um and if you actually look, and you can
click into them, you can kind of see
what was that prompt that the main agent
passed into the sub agent to do, right?
It will all happen in parallel, so I can
go back to the main agent. And as you
can see, the the the sub agents are
reporting back to the main agent, "Hey,
I I've just finished my task. Here's
some information as you asked me to."
And that main agent can now take that
information and synthesize that
together.
Right? So, this is just a really simple
example
of sub agents in action. So, that's not
the only place that we try to improve
um the the core agentic experience. Um
the second one is we decided we realized
that, you know, okay, you're starting a
new project, a lot of time actually
spends in commands like installing
packages, right? Or or or doing updates.
And you know, you're you're the agent's
doing all this exciting work, and then
like, boom, you just waiting there for 5
minutes, right? For all these packages
to to install or update. Uh it turns out
there's a lot of tasks like these that
are just long-running commands that can
actually happen asynchronously in the
background. So, asynchronous kind of uh
processes and asynchronous task
management is now kind of a core
primitive within antigravity.
Um so I want to see whether or not that
actually happened
in in this conversation I had over here.
Do. Let's see if it worked. Um yeah, so
you can actually see like, you know,
this running these these uh these
installation commands actually happened
in the background and once it was
completed, it kind of reported back that
hey, this this background task this
background command got completed. So
this is also will allow your agents,
just like subagents allow you to
paralyze, this is another kind of core
primitive that we've added to make sure
that that your task can can get done
quicker. In fact, these two things
actually compound with each other,
right? You can imagine the agent
launching subagents in the background.
It can do its work while it can continue
doing its work. So,
you know,
actually what was happening here, if I
remember correctly, all the installation
was happening while the main agent was
writing the code.
And so by the end, the packages are
ready, the code is ready, I could
actually boot the app just like that.
Right, so these are some of the core
primitives that we're playing together.
The third kind of core primitive that we
added to agents was this idea of hooks.
Um so these are kind of, you know,
programmatic pieces that you can
actually have your own custom script and
this is all defined in a JSON file, it's
all in our documentation, uh where you
can actually tell, "Hey, every time
before you run this specific tool or
before you stop um your your turn, make
sure you run this script." So what's a
really good example of this? Maybe after
every conversation, you want in the
agents to run some kind of validity
checks
that are specifically to you or your
company. You can define that in a custom
script, you can install you can register
that as a hook for that stop command and
it will make sure the agent will make
sure that that is actually always called
programmatically. But so this is
actually ways for you to be able to
inject your own custom logic into the
agent's behavior.
So,
a lot of kind of abstract topics, but
these are all ideas that we've actually
tried to bring into antigravity 2.0 so
the agents are more powerful in this in
this interface.
Um
so that's
so some of the agent pieces. But, let
walk a little bit more more through the
app. I was kind of going through this
right-hand panel a little bit. We talked
about sub-agents. We talked about
background tasks. Actually, the npm run
dev is still running, so you actually
can see that that that's that's up. Um
we what we also show is what we like to
call artifacts. Right? These are
essentially, if your agents were running
for longer and longer
by themselves autonomously, we want to
make sure that they can communicate
their progress to you in ways that you
understand. Right?
You could already see me kind of go
through this conversation. I was like
scrolling through and I'm like, "Uh-huh,
what happened in this whole
conversation? What happened where?"
It's a lot of text, and it's a lot of
tool calls, and these agents are doing a
lot. So, that's not always kind of the
best view into knowing what the agent
did. So, artifacts are essentially these
ideas of, you know, they could be
markdown files, they could be code
changes of, "Hey, this is something that
I actually want you to look at." Um that
will actually tell you a little bit
about what I'm doing, so that you can
build your trust in the agents, and you
can know that the agents aren't going in
the right directions. So, for example,
at the very beginning of this task,
it generated an implementation plan.
Right? So,
this is like, "Hey, this is what I'm
planning to do." All that. The nice
thing about all these artifacts actually
is that you can comment on them. So, you
know, whether they're text artifacts,
visual artifacts like screenshots and
other than that, you can leave comments.
So, this is kind of one where it's like,
"Hey, this is my plan. This is what I
want to do."
If you're like, "Actually, no." Instead
of trying to battle with the agent back
and forth, if there's just some small
nuance you want to do, just leave online
comments, and and um the agent will
incorporate that as it continues doing
its work. So, this is kind of one way
for you to kind of guide the guide the
agent. Um other other things happened.
It kind of had a walk-through after it
was all done.
Um a task list. And of course, it also
changed some files, right? So, I can go
through all the files that changed. And
one thing that we did in Ant Gravity 2.0
that it wasn't there in the agent
manager in the IDE is that we made it a
pretty easy flow to actually review your
code also inline. Right? So, write some
code. If you really want to get in there
in the nitty-gritty, the entire review
flow is now directly in Antigravity 2.0.
Cool. So, those are some of the kinds of
things to on the right-hand panel, which
is really your way of investigating into
that agent conversation and knowing
what's going on.
But as I said in the beginning,
I will say agent a lot. Our goal is that
you guys are actually running many
agents in parallel across all your
projects. Maybe a multiple ideas you
have, you know, the app that Joanna
built and you built and brought it down
locally and
into Antigravity and you're like,
"Actually, I have this idea and this
idea and this idea." Our goal is that
you should be able to fire all these all
these agents in parallel and it should
work. So, we spent a lot of time
actually redesigning what does this left
sidebar look like? And it might not seem
like a whole lot, but there's actually a
lot of kind of ideas here. Um the first
is this idea of projects. So,
historically, um we had kind of, you
know, agents tied to repositories.
That was kind of the the core primitive,
right? You have a code repository, an
agent that works on it.
We decided to actually broaden that a
little bit more. So, project is kind of
just a general purpose,
you know, collection of resources that
an agent can work on and and and uh
you can apply permissions on. So, what
do I mean by that? I have this like
to-do app project. I can go to the
project settings. You can actually
connect multiple project multiple
folders to the same project. So, if you
actually want your agents to be working
across multiple repositories, you have a
microservice-based system, whatever it
might be, that's actually really easy.
You now don't need two agents in the two
different repositories to try to work
with each other. You just create a
project that actually allows those
particular agents to access
those extra repositories at the same
time and they'll be able to make edits
across all of those.
The other thing that we ended up doing
is we ended up creating projects so that
you can define settings and permissions
at the project level.
Right? I think we all know that
I think we've all seen things online of
agents kind of going wild, deleting a
bunch of things that you didn't expect
it to delete and like, you're like, how
did I end up in this world? And really a
lot of that boils down to that
you know, as your agents do more and
more work, it's very natural for us to
be able to just give more and more
permissions to your agents. Right?
Actually, you know, like, stop asking me
to approve every single one of my
commands, which is the default kind of
behavior for all these agents. Um
And and next thing you know, all your
agents can do pretty much anything on
your your computer. Um
as as you probably guessed by how I
framed it, that's not the most kind of
secure way of going about building with
agents. So, what we're allowing you to
do with projects is for you to be able
to define those permissions and settings
at the project level. So, that means
only the agents within this project have
these kind of scope scopes that are
permissions. So, you can specify which
kind of files that you actually want to
allow it to access outside of the you
know, outside of the um folders that
you've connected it to.
Um you know, what are the kind of
different review policies, the terminal
commands. So, for example, like
you can say, always allow these kinds of
commands, never allow these other kinds
of commands. And if you're working in
repositories that you know have like
more kind of critical code, you might
give fewer permissions and ask and want
the agent to ask you more frequently
every single time it wants to run a
command. If it's just kind of your to-do
app like here, you might just say, go
wild, build something as long as it's
not like r m r f or something like that,
right? Like, you'll give it a whole lot
more permissions. So, this is kind of
the direction that we want to go to.
This kind of core primitive of a project
that we're introducing that allows you
to
you know, kind of have agents in ways
that aren't just necessarily
particularly tied to a single
repository. It's actually tied to a
whole lot more.
So, a lot of stuff to kind of um
uh explore here, and all the
customizations, your MCP tools, your
skills, all of those things you can
attach and you can uh you can also see a
breakdown of how you're using your
tokens
um within the system prompts uh
efficiently.
Cool.
All right, what else do we want to show
around here? Um
there's a bunch of other kind of fun
little uh tidbits that are that are
within
um the product. As you probably saw on
stage during the developer keynote,
there's now a live audio transcription.
Um
I will say I don't think maybe every
single Google office has been well
designed for everyone talking to their
computers, but um
that's the new reality, I guess. Uh but
it's you know, I think there's research
that the talking is like 5x or something
faster than than typing. And so um
sometimes when I just have an an idea,
I'll just go and kind of talk to to the
agent. Um and one of the really nice
things about the audio model here is it
isn't just like you know, one-to-one
live transcription. It's actually using
our latest audio models that will
synthesize and remove all your filler
words and make sure they have like kind
of cohesive thoughts so that the prompts
that you're sending to the agent are
actually well-formed ideas. Um so
all my ums kind of go away.
Which is great. Um
some more features that we've added. Uh
everything that I've shown so far uh
has you kind of working synchronously
with an agent, which is still, you know,
a pretty important uh paradigm for
people working with agents. But I mean,
I think you guys all saw some of the
stats with like Gemini 3.5 flash like
earlier today, right? It's a it's a it's
a workhorse of a model. We've been using
it internally for a couple of weeks and
it's it's been crazy. And on
antigravity, we've been able to do
further infra optimization so that it
runs about 12x faster than frontier
models. So we see somewhere up to like
700, 800 tokens per second being
produced. So it's like
you run it and the the thoughts kind of
pass before you even have a look time
time to look at it. So it's a really
really fast model, but at the same time
a very very powerful model as well. And
on every benchmark and every single AB
test that we've run kind of internally
with with uh Googlers. Um and so
with that kind of increased
intelligence, it really got us thinking
like, okay, we're still going to
definitely start moving to a world where
people are just going to want agents to
run
in the background for them
asynchronously. It require me having to
kick off every single agent every single
time I have a conversation. In my
day-to-day, I have a lot of tasks that I
pretty much do
on a regular cadence, right? Every
morning, I will, you know, use an use an
agent to kind of make a digest of kind
of all of the, you know, PRs that are
open that I are open to review and like
what's actually high priority, what's
not, like all of that. I I like to have
a digest. These are kind of like really
common things that we want to have on
some kind of cron schedule, right? You
launch a new
um job on on GCP. You want to make sure
that there's there's no issues and
realistically, if there are any issues,
I would
kind of want an agent to first do a
first pass of debugging on what the
issue is um before I have to actually
dive in. So, these are all kind of
common examples of where you want an
agent to be doing something on a
schedule.
Kind of layered that to kind of uh talk
about scheduled tasks. Um
not very clever. Uh uh uh
But, that's pretty much the basic idea.
Uh the the simple thing here is you just
made it really simple. You schedule
task. You enter kind of task name, like,
you know, daily digest. You set the
project so that the agents that are spun
up kind of on the schedule will obey all
the same permissions and everything that
you have for that project. On a daily
schedule, yeah, 9:00 a.m. looks good.
You put in your prompt, you know,
summarize my PRs or or whatever, dot dot
dot dot. And um you just add the
scheduled task and it's there. It It's
It's really that simple. And so, those
tasks, those agents will show up in your
project as they're run. You can check in
whenever you want and be like, "Okay,
that looks good." And because they're
responding here, if you want to follow
up questions, this is all a
conversation. So, you just go in there,
you pick up the conversation, you
continue.
All right. Um
I remember having this UI and someone's
like, "Actually,
what I what I really want is I don't
even want to go to another panel. Can
you just like have a slash command?" So,
we introduced some new slash commands.
So, there's slash schedule. So, you can
actually just describe in natural
language, "Hey, every 9:00 a.m. put me
digest running this project and we will
generate that schedule task for you.
So, explain natural language don't even
need a form. Forms are so, I don't know,
2025 I don't know.
Um
but we have a few others
um that we that we put here. So,
often agents will come back and they'll
ask you feedback like that
implementation plan something like that.
But sometimes you know like hey just
keep on pushing through. Don't ask me
for feedback just
make your best decisions and and kind of
get to an output when you actually think
the job is terminated. That's what slash
goal is for. So, slash goal is like hey
here's my goal just keep driving.
You don't need my input just go for it.
Slash schedule we just talked about. Uh
slash browser um one of the favorite
features when we launched the
antigravity IDE was the fact that the
agent is fully capable of spinning up a
browser sub agent of itself
using the Chrome DevTools MCP to
actually actuate the browser. So, if
you're building an app the agent can go
out test the app itself give you some
feedback and and take screen recordings.
So, slash browser essentially just tells
your agent hey make sure you use
um you kind of your browser tools in the
browser sub agent do that.
Grill me is a fun one um which is like
I don't know about you but I sometimes
write the vaguest and dumbest prompts.
Um so, grill me just essentially is a
way to like hey first ask me clarifying
questions
um so that we get to a good point before
you actually go out and start
implementing things.
Um
I probably missed honestly quite a few
features uh that that we we introduced
here in in antigravity 2.0 and I've not
even talked to yet about the antigravity
CLI, the antigravity SDK, um the
antigravity agent in the managed API.
So, we're really trying to bring this
agent and this agent harness that has
been co-optimized with the Gemini models
um to you all in any kind of way that
you
find best. So, if you looked at all this
and for the last 20 minutes you're like
Anshul I absolutely hate a GUI bring me
a terminal. Don't worry we have that
covered. I just don't have time today.
Um try out the antigravity CLI. And if
you're a developer who like, "Hey, you
know, these agents can do really
powerful things. Gemini 3.5 flash is a
very powerful model.
I want to start integrating that to my
own projects. I want to do some kind of
research on that." There's both, as I
mentioned, the the
managed agent within the interactions
API, as well as the anti-gravity SDK,
which will allow you to actually take
that same harness, but customize parts
like the system instructions, the tools,
all these kind of customizations of the
agent, and and allow you to kind of
deploy that wherever you want to deploy.
So, a lot that's been announced in the
last, I don't know, eight or so hours
here at I/O, and I'm sure there's going
to be even more that's going to be
talked about, but I think we're roughly
wrapping up on time. So, I think we're
going to start start wrapping it up and
let you guys get to the
block party.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean
Well, I only have two last questions for
you.
One is
who's ready to build?
Yes. Yes. And who's ready to go to the
block party?
Okay. Okay.
>> louder.
>> That was louder, wasn't it?
>> know about that. We'll We'll have to
work on that one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think we've seen so many
cool things here at I/O. We shared the
latest and greatest from Google AI
Studio and anti-gravity. As you could
see, there's so many new updates and new
features that we introduced today, and
more coming soon as well. So, keep the
feedback coming because that's how we
can co-build these products together
with the community. That's really
important to us. I literally show you
how you can build a new business
entirely from scratch with AI Studio in
like 20 minutes or so. And then you can
take it to the next level with
anti-gravity. So, no better time than
starting today.
And thank you. Enjoy the rest of your
I/O.
>> Thank you.
>> [music]